one of the really good things about
getting world leaders together at events
like the g20 in Argentina this past
weekend is that climate change is a
bigger and bigger topic it's clear
climate change as bill scher mentioned
earlier in the show is going to be a
main topic for the next House of
Representatives the next Congress and
it's a major topic around the world
because with consensus we can build
momentum and the bummer on all of this
is that it's a conversation that's
basically no longer including the United
States of America given Donald Trump's
position that climate change is a hoax
created by the Chinese and his decision
to back the u.s. out of the Paris
climate agreement is part of the United
States simply not being taken seriously
anymore on this issue the two big topics
at this year's g20 were climate change
and trade on climate change 19 countries
signed on to a communique which affirmed
support of the Paris climate change
agreement and to go into the playa
climate change talks upcoming in Poland
ready to make progress and do the right
thing 19 of the 20 countries did that
one country did not do I even need to
tell you which of the 20 countries did
not sign on to the climate change
communique of course not it was
obviously Trump and the United States
the communique signed by the 19 other
countries had to have a separate section
for the United States which said simply
quote the United States reiterates its
decision to withdraw from the Paris
agreement and affirms its strong
commitment to economic growth and energy
access and security utilizing all energy
sources and technology while protecting
the environment 19 of the 20 countries
on board the Paris agreement is not a
solution in and of itself but it is
something that everybody can say yes
we're on the same page and then we can
do more
and then there's Donald Trump's United
States of America Vladimir Putin Saudi
Arabia even they are on board with this
but not Trump do it even for the wrong
reasons there's a case to be made that
for example China is only part of this
because the optics are getting really
bad for them that China's such a
polluter and people are suffering from
the disastrous air quality and they need
to almost stymie revolt by appearing to
before reducing emissions and fighting
climate change at the national level at
least they're doing it as we spoke about
last week Pat India a leader on
renewables and climate change at this
point everyone and we have to be a
laughingstock an embarrassment every
single day there's no reason not to sign
it really it's not like by signing the
communique you're going to place a bunch
of new regulations on fossil fuel
companies back home or that you know a
bunch of coal jobs are gonna be lost it
really is just a formal agreement that's
all it is and they even had a little
stipulation for you saying that you're
not getting back into the Paris the
climate Accord but you are going to try
to do something at least on paper and he
couldn't do it every time I look at the
news some new boneheaded childish
childish antic by Donald Trump and the
craziest part of all of this is that
Trump says I'm gonna bring back
manufacturing I'm gonna bring back jobs
the US will be respected the US could
have been retooled and reconfigured
years ago Obama didn't do enough george
w bush did almost nothing and the US
could be the world leader in green
manufacturing in green energy in solar
in wind in electric batteries it would
revitalize the economy it would
revitalize the auto industry which is
struggling so significantly it would fix
all of the things that Trump claims to
want to fix but is actually ruining but
we didn't do it there was no political
will we subsidize all of the wrong
industries like fossil fuels and oil and
because we have a huge portion of
elected officials who don't even believe
in climb
change the world is laughing at us and
this is not some day off in the future
this is now this is something that every
day that we don't do something about it
we need two days to undo that day of
damage right we are digging a hole with
a bigger and bigger shovel if to use an
analogy and Trump is at the head of it
and the United States is a joke around
the world as a result I am thrilled to
tell you that today's episode is
sponsored in part by Blink accom slash
Pakman Blink astiz a really unique
service for your phone tablet and web
browser and it is incredibly useful for
people like me who love books and
learning but are busy blinka stakes the
best and most popular non-fiction books
and condenses them into 15-minute
audiobooks I'm sure that if you're like
me you have a very long list of books
that you've been meaning to read you
only have so many hours in the day and
that's why blink astiz so amazing they
take the most important information the
themes the insights from each book and
they distill it into a 15 minute audio
book that you can listen to in one
sitting I've listened to a ton of books
on blankets our audience can get a seven
day free trial by going to blink accom
slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube i've put a link in the
description I have listened to blinka
spokes about economics about political
science about history about science so
many interesting things and after the
free trial if you like it you can
continue enjoying thousands of condensed
audiobooks for about five bucks a month
go to blink accom slash Pakman that's
bli n ki st.com /pa ke ma n